Hey, what's going on it's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and
just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on,
oh,
how are you? How are you
everybody? Oh my goodness.
I am down in my last
couple of gigs of the year.
Other than a couple of
benefits or whatever. The last
couple of gigs of the year.
I got Madison Square Garden coming up
on November 7th and then the eighth,
ninth and 10th I'm going to be at,
um,
at the Chicago theater and then that's it.
Oh,
freckles has done for the year other
than a thousand other fucking local
bullshit things that I'm doing.
Uh, yeah. So November 7th,
I'll be at Madison Square Garden, but I'm
going to be doing a tuneup show, wink,
wink,
nudge,
nudge at a comedy club somewhere
in Manhattan on November 5th,
a comedy club.
That might be on the west side.
It might be a comedy club.
Um, a west side comedy club.
November 5th, I don't know.
Might be running my hour.
Who knows? I might be there.
I'm going to be there on November
5th. And uh, I love that place.
I love the people that run it.
I'm going to be there.
I'm going to be bouncing around all
over Manhattan, having a great time. Um,
getting ready to do that show.
And I'm going to do the MSG with
Versie and Joe Barton. Nick,
I'm going to record that night, this time.
We're going to get it right. And, uh,
I am really, really, really, really
looking forward to that. Um, what else?
What else did I have to announce
here? Uh, before the throwback,
there will be a teaser of the,
uh,
the first uninformed Patriot episode.
Patrion goes live,
no vent live November 5th,
next Monday at
www.patrion.com/bar. I got all this
extra backstage shit at the forum.
I'm fly in helicopters. I'm
showing you some, some of my, my,
my beauty secrets,
skincare,
stupid shit. Um, and that is all. And Oh,
you know what?
We might have a special guest on this
podcast as special guests that I'm married
to, that I love to death. Who's the
best thing that ever happened? Me?
But she's still,
you know,
Piss me off today and I've been doing
such a good job not having arguments with
her. And I kind of shook it off and then
she said something else to me in the
kitchen. And, uh, I add
the, you know, you know,
there are moments where you just
have to be like, hey, you know,
you can't talk to me like
that. All right, I'm over here.
I'm being a swell guy and, and
you know, so you should be,
be in a sweetheart and I'm just
not, I'm not feeling that, you know,
feeling like I'm being like a swell
guy and someone else's not being a
sweetheart then, then I become a
jerk off. Oh look who just came in.
The person I was talking about,
I'm doing the math here,
the lovely Nia, everybody, the greatest
thing that ever happened to me though.
Yeah. Although if you behave the
way you did this morning every time,
you'd be one of the worst things
that ever happened to me. Oh,
doesn't that sound sincere everybody?
I apologize.
All right. Are you going to sit
down on the couch? Yes. So anyways,
um, I'm sitting there, you know,
mine in my own business and,
uh,
am I plugged in? Here you go.
You sit down. You sat down. Um,
so nia, hi. How are you? This is
going to be a little therapy session.
No, no it isn't. It isn't, but
you know, you know what I mean?
I get I lovely daughter up. I
guess you said to me, to my face.
I got these things a little too
loud. Let me turn this down here. Um,
you said to my evidently fee,
she said that you go, you know,
I come upstairs, right? I
worked out. You had a wonderful,
I work out where I put all this shit. Hey,
quit breathing into the mic
there. Breathing. Um, yeah,
I put all somebody's gonna fucking put
that clip on a loop and jerk off to it.
That's how creepy the Internet is
and have fun. Have Fun with that.
Anyways, um, I put all this shit
from the kid Halloween party,
broke that all down,
put it in the back of my truck.
I noticed that it wasn't your, yeah, get
all of that. I went to the gym. Right.
Yeah. Being a hell of a
guy. I go upstairs. Right.
All adorable qd face doesn't
want to get up. Yup. Yup.
She likes to sleep like somebody.
I know. I think that's so adorable.
We got this thing now we come and
sometimes now when she doesn't,
when you take the blanket off her and
she has this little mischievous grin,
she pulls the blanket back
over. Yeah. She wasn't ready.
She just was staying lying down and she
wanted me to get the blanket on her.
I was like, come on, it's time to get up.
And she was just smiling at me like, nope,
not feeling it. Yeah, it was cute.
I just want to stay here for another
couple of 20 minutes. So anyway,
so you leave blanket.
It's a little chilly.
That was probably your vibe today. Oh. Um,
so right. I get her out of bed. You leave.
And evidently at some point you said to
me, hey bill, put her in this outfit.
Hey Bill, put her in this outfit.
And she said to me, here's her,
here's her outfit for the day.
How many times did you say is
once you told me in the kitchen,
you said you said it twice.
I sent it to you said I said to you
twice and you said it to my what? No,
I said it to your face. To my face. That's
way you said it. You were like that cop.
You like to copy reservoir dogs,
buddy.
I am going to shoot you in the face.
You don't put that outfit on our daughter.
So I didn't hear and I saw that
brewed sweatshirt. I put her in that,
you know via Kaitlin. Can you
make more noise? I'm sorry. Sorry.
Sorry.
What are you doing?
I was trying to take
the tag off this Blake.
Okay, I'm done. I'm done. I'm here.
I'm present and paying attention.
I don't understand why your
Mike is so frigging loud.
It's like literally you just moving your
hand. It's making it do all this stuff.
All right.
Anyways.
MMM,
yeah. So anyways, so then you're sitting
there, right? Shit, a poopy diaper.
Handled all of that crap, literally.
Right? And then you come in, you're like,
oh wait. Yeah, yeah.
[inaudible] you doing? I'm just
like, oh, I'm sorry. She goes, yeah,
why would you do that? I go, well,
she can go to wherever the whatever
event she's going to in this, right?
You're like,
yeah,
but you know it's not going to be
is breathable is what I put out.
So then you leave. So I was
like, all right. By the way,
she's standing there adorable eating the
homemade pumpkin bread than I made last
night.
I'm a sweet guy. I'm a
made guy. I'm a swell guy.
Right. So then you leave. And
so what do I own? This points,
if you guys can recognize where that quote
is from, I'll come on. That's it. Easy.
Yeah.
I'm a guy.
Just pull it a little away from your
mouth. Yeah, maybe like right here.
Hap split the difference now. Little
more closer. How about this? Here you go.
Will you keep adjusting the level that
you're talking? That's fine. Anyways,
so then I change.
I change her into the outfit that you
said and you come walking in like nothing
happened. So I jokingly
say, Hey dad, thanks for Ra.
Putting her in the earth on the
other outfit. And then you just like,
why do I have to say thanks? I told you
to put her, put her in that outfit twice
face and then you walked out.
Yes.
Individually in defense.
Shout out to uh, um, what's,
what is it? Oh my God. Fat Cells.
Fat cells are transforming fat
Sal's and two Mcdowell's yeah.
From coming into him.
Sorry,
I just accidentally hit
that fricking button there.
Reach for reaching for my smoothie.
Where the hell were we? Oh, fat cells.
Fat Sal's turned it into what?
A Mcdowell's.
And then they also had like
on the side of the building,
they had a big printout and as
an employee of the month, uh,
Keem and as a picture of, you know,
Eddie Murphy from the movie and,
and as Jerry Ferrara. That's right.
That's right. Um, our lovely Powell,
Jerry Ferrara. Why did you have
to throw that in Hollywood? Huh?
You can't just say it's owned by him.
Your,
you always got to do it anyways because
you want to say something like say I
have my nice about the person so then I
don't know. Yeah, so then you just like,
yeah, I told you that twice,
right? I never knew this.
I didn't say it like that to your face.
That's how you just sat in the kitchen
to your face. So I know yell anymore.
That's my thing. I kissed. Keep
saying that Baja. Ha Ha no,
until you're a fucking jerk. They
had something. I mean it is, it is.
There's a reason human beings are able
to yell because God knew that some of
them that he made were jerks.
So anyways, then I, I walk,
I'm the king of Mulder and now
I'll put the outfit on and you get a
bucket tanker area and I fucking go
downstairs and I'm making a smoothie.
All right.
And the lea and the thing is not supposed
to turn on the food processors not
supposed to turn on unless you have
the whole thing close and it turned on
anyways and stuff is going all over the
place and then you come over you like,
it's like all over my shirt.
So I give you the look you deserved. I
thought it was like leaking from the top.
I didn't think he realized that it
was coming. No, not from the top.
From the bottom side.
And I don't know.
I didn't think that you realize that
most of that look was because of your,
your thing upstairs in the face.
Right.
So then we're downstairs and
I was just like, hey, you
know, not for nothing. Yeah.
I didn't appreciate you could've
said thank you and you like,
why do I have to say thank you bill?
I told you two times to your face.
That's what you said. And I was just
like, yeah. And then that's when,
that's when I snapped.
I still was saying effin in GED,
not using the actual words. Right, right,
right. I was just like, you're not. Yeah.
You're not going to talk to me like that.
I'm not going to be a sweetheart and then
be taught to like a jerk because then
I become a jerk off.
I'd become a typical
Staten island jerk off.
I can't believe we're still quoting
that show. So many. I love that.
I love that for people never saw that
we watch some reality show and there was
this woman from Staten Island shoe
life. I'm a Staten island girl. Okay.
Like the MTV show. True Life.
I'm a blank. This is true life.
She went into New York,
the city into the city.
She went to a club, she was dancing with
a guy. She had a long island ice tea.
She's dancing with this guy
and as he's dancing with her,
he's like sorta grabbing his girl. Her
girlfriend too. Yeah. And she's like,
are you like, you like grabbing all my
girlfriend? Like why you dance with me?
And the guy's like,
what were the Dayton?
And then they just cut to her
outside of the club and she goes,
that was your typical
Staten island jerk off.
No, I thought, he says, well, we're
not married or something like that.
What do we married? Something like
that. Something to that effect.
[inaudible] anyways, he was going for
the threesome and he had just met her.
Got To respect that there's no
loyalty in the club. Oh Shit.
I think that, I think that's got to be,
I think that's got to be on a tee shirt.
But you gotta say you gotta Say
da in Duck Club? No, can't say t.
H. E. T. H. E. Then you think
maybe it's a white club.
Like what are you talking about? The
White House. I know, but like Senate,
so over Donald, when people write
down whatever on tee shirts,
it's just like coordinates the finger
on the pulse. Social media, Marnie.
Oh, it is. What are the top three emojis?
A,
the top of the emojis or the face?
The one where the eyes are
closed. The mouth. It's kind
of like, ah, like, oh my God,
I can't believe this is happening phase.
These are my top three. I love that one.
I also love the finger on the Chin One
m one and then I also liked the one
eyebrow raised. Awesome.
Those are my faves.
You want to hear mine
and the crying laughing.
Of course you want to hit my what are
you already have one? What? The thumbs up
that covers everything. Yes. Yes,
I heard you point. Yeah.
Noncommittal. That sounds good.
I feel you didn't one of the biggest
fucking assholes I've ever met.
She started like,
you know that thumbs up
speaking of which? Yes, I
got a text message. So wait,
do you forgive me for yeah.
And I'll tell you though and I'll
tell you why I do apologize. It was,
it was over the top and I'll tell you why.
Cause I'm done.
I'm done being the angry guy. I don't
give a shit anymore. I'm not too much in.
My life has gone by. I'm on, I'm
on like fucking the 13th hole here.
What am I doing right? 50 years
old. That's a golf reference,
but I don't know what that 13 is. Only
at towards the end there's only 18 holes.
Oh, so you only have five
more holes lives 50 okay.
You live to 80 that's a great
run. Although I am drinking. No,
we're going to live longer that
remember I, I'm calling it right now.
You are going to be like the Don Rickles
of your generation and we're going to
like live in Las Vegas.
You and I were going to live in
Las Vegas for like however long.
They want to book you for like,
Oh,
we want to give him a year or
a year residency at this place.
We're going to live in Vegas. We're going
to live in one of those like obnoxious,
like Penthouse, five rooms suites
in Vegas. It sounds horrible.
Horrible. You're going to go
downstairs and be like, hey
[inaudible] her old just be
pulled out and the jokes.
Old people tell I'm going to be like
shopping at Caesar's and having lunch at
the same place every day. They're
going to know it's going to be great.
You kidding me? It's going to be so much
fun. You're going to shop at Caesars? Yep.
Yep. Cause I have all the stores you're
acting like there's just one store and
Caesar's.
It's like all the stores that you know,
every time we go to Vegas with there
for about 36 hours, you're like,
I gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
That's true.
But I feel like as like you're going to
live on the Strip in Las Vegas and this,
this is how you're going to go
out and your golden years. Well,
I mean I'm 10 years younger than you,
so I'm not going anywhere for a while.
But God,
God willing,
knock on what I'm just saying that
that would just be fun. Like if you're,
and I'm 70 yeah.
Why wouldn't we just like live in Vegas?
Why not? Yeah. I'm not going
out like that. New Ad. No
one saying you're going out,
but like the, there's a very
high can live in fucking Vegas.
Did he do Vegas? Yeah, he did Vegas
and then you get the fuck out of there.
You get another gig.
You think you're going to be on the
road like that when you're 80 years old?
Yeah. First of all, I ever retire. At some
point and just do like a nice local gig.
Yeah. It doesn't have to be in Las
Vegas. I'm a fucking redhead knee.
I'm not going to be with global warming
by the time I'm 80 is going to be 140
degrees out in the winter.
You'd are you doing stand up
out in the desert like no.
You're inside all those old
people that live in Vegas.
They stay inside the whole time and
Erica and one heat wave like five of them
die. Yeah, because I can't make it over
to their fucking air conditioner. I know,
but those are probably the ones who
aren't doing so well financially,
so they can't afford, they don't
matter. Oh Wow. They don't matter.
I'm going to out of that that like,
you know,
chances are they're in
places that don't have good
close with because I wear a silly
grin the moment you come into view.
There's a lot of older people
who live in Las Vegas, Bill,
so I'm just saying you're
going to be an going again.
You're going to be an air
conditioning and you'll be fine.
I'm not going to be there.
I have a plan. Okay.
And is your plan, Huh? I should
probably know what this plant is. Yeah.
Well it doesn't evolve.
Fucking living in a shop at it's Caesar's.
God live in Las Vegas.
Obnoxious fucking penthouse.
Yeah. Look at him hall.
Look at them all down there.
How'd he get away from the
window? Yes. Skin cancer.
Oh your ass.
That point.
We'll be sleeping in different suites.
Jesus Christ.
What was the topic you were
about to talk about? Oh,
getting back those arms up. I favorite
emojis. Oh the thumbs up. All right.
So this is thing going on
on the Internet right now.
Cause all Yankee fans are pissed at,
not all young for it,
but a lot of Yankee fans
are pissed at Boston,
at the Boston Red Sox fans that
are talking shit. Right, right.
There's different kinds of sports fans.
This is sports fan that goes, hey man,
great series you sons of bitches, you beat
us, whatever. And you leave it at that.
Okay.
Then there's the middle guys who just
won't be friends with anybody who's a fan
of another team.
And then there's the worst of the worst,
which are just the shit talk and assholes
who talked fucking shit all the time.
And then when their team loses,
if you can find them,
cause they go into hiding to give
him the shit back that they deserve,
they then act as though
they don't understand where
this is coming from and have
the audacity to be like, oh,
class act plus act. Right. So,
um, I don't engage in any of
that. Okay. Right. Like, uh,
there's some hilarious stuff on the
Internet right now with um, you know,
shit talking red sox fans had shit-talking
Yankee fence. One of them is like,
one of them were cut,
few Yankee fans had the audacity to say
the Red Sox bought the uh, world series.
Oh, they're mad, Huh? Well it's just like,
well where did we learn how to do that?
You assholes.
They,
they're spending 20 million a year for
like 20 years and this is the first like
couple last couple of years they've
gone with their farm system,
which is brilliant.
And they're going to get another one and
they're going to get another one soon.
[inaudible] is what I think.
As much as I don't want that
to happen as a red sox fan,
I'm also a fan of baseball.
I love what they're doing.
So it's just like all you guys,
all they're doing is stockpiling their
cash and they're going to go out and
they're going to spend a ton of fucking
money and they're going to come out with
whatever the hell you need
to spend now to 228 million.
Is that what it is that what we spent?
Um,
and then also go on real
classy real class. He talking
shit, Bah, blah blah, blah,
blah. If the Yankees won, we wouldn't
have said shit about red sox fans.
It's like the fuck you
wouldn't the fuck you wasn't,
I remember when you want them
and what you said, I was there.
I don't know what you
guys are talking about.
You guys through beer in the face
of one of our relievers this year.
It's stop acting like you're class and
now I'm at face and the face. So anyways,
this was the day after,
I'm not gonna say who this person is,
but he's a very emotional
person and I love him.
And I've done his podcast and he's done
my podcast and he's one of the funniest
people I know. I love this guy, but
he's out of his fucking mind. Um,
he sends me a text at 12:34 PM he writes,
you know,
Pedro Martinez Sucks.
Big Fat Elephant Cox still,
he's still suck in elephant dicks.
So I write back, thanks so-and-so.
Exclamation point. God bless, exclamation
point, right? And he just keeps going.
He goes, he doesn't care. He doesn't
clean them either. He just sucks.
Elephant Cock only person
still rock and a Jheri curl.
So then I write back the number 11,
and he's still in the middle of his rent.
He goes, I'm a bad guy now, cause
he's, cause he's still sucks cock.
And then he takes the bait and he
goes, 11 what? And I go, championships,
five Superbowls, four world series,
one NBA, title one Stanley Cup,
1417 years. You'll tell your grandchildren
about it. And then he just writes back,
you've changed man.
And then he continues, whatever, man,
you didn't bring back that animal
Schilling in his fake bloody socks.
And I just never responded. So
I don't under, I don't, I'm,
I'm done near you don't understand it.
Like I'm going to have relapses.
Like when you bait me two times in the
face, right? That might send me back,
but I am done with this shit.
You just rolled your eyes.
You know what is this nith you know,
you know in your heart of hearts,
if I fucking beat this thing,
you got nothing on me. You do.
I work hard and make a
great living mean not
having a shotgun.
You
absolutely absolute fucking lucidly.
Are you kidding me?
Does shut your cute little face up. I love
you to death. Now I love you to death,
but you know, you know something.
Could you quit yawning into the mix?
The Fun fucking dental
office waiting room.
All right. I need it on the
podcast and so long. Yeah, long.
I know when people Miss Jen, I
missed Ya. Well, I'm back baby.
I'm back bitches.
I need to, uh, I need to read some
advertising here. This first one's called
nobody.
What?
That's the sound to your voice,
right as I'm walking out the
door to go do something fun.
I just hear you from upstairs.
Swing by is always the opposite direction.
20 fucking miles.
I was going to ask you to bring home some
bananas on the way back from the gym,
but I thought better of it. Oh, you
did? I still would've done it, you know,
but I was like, no,
he's always saying that.
I always ask him to give you something
the other day cause I'm, I'm,
I'm just like, yeah, fuck this.
This is going to be equal.
I asked you all my buddies were coming
up for the world series. I just went, oh,
you skipped a few steps there. What did
I skip? You asked me to go get some beer.
Yeah. And you said, okay.
Oh Geez. And then yeah.
And then a half hour later you're
still laying there and I'm like, Mija,
you gotta go get that beer. And
you're like, oh, you were serious.
It's like, yeah, we're serious in my
row when you told me, so I was like,
you know you had a half hour to get
out of the room. Not to mention, yeah,
it was one in the afternoon. Fucking
laying around like Cruella Deville.
All right, let me, was this
Sunday? No, it wasn't. Yeah,
it wasn't, wasn't a Saturday.
It was Saturday. Can you
please put that back please?
Put that back.
Why can't I look at it?
Put that down because I can look
at stuff that's in here now.
It's covered. No, it's a
fucking bets and Elvin Jones,
modern drummer magazine. I see
that. It's a very like, you know,
like it's obviously like there's item and,
but I can't like pick
it up and look at it.
I wasn't going to take it out
of the packaging. All right.
Can I just read the
advertising? Yeah. All right.
Nobody wants to feel like they're
overpaying while shopping online,
but did you know there's an easy way to
always get the lowest price? It's called,
I don't know why they picked this name.
Honey is a free shopping tool that
automatically saves you money,
honey.
Honey,
that is me though. Yeah, by the Internet.
For the best promo codes.
Whenever you shop online,
that means you get the best deals without
ever trying on your favorite sites.
What would that be?
Trying on.
That means you get the best deals without
even trying on your favorite sites
like Amazon, Ebay, Walmart, best buy.
Okay.
New Wig, new egg, Etsy, Groupon in more.
In fact,
honey has our listeners of this
podcast and average of $46 and 8 cents.
Honey does it does it all for you.
It always applies the biggest discount.
Write a check scout
honey has saved the over,
has has over 10 million members and over
a hundred thousand five star reviews.
There's no reason not to add. Hi. Hey,
do your browser today.
Get honey for free and join
honey.com/birth that's two words.
Join honey.com/burr Heidi,
the easiest way to save
money while shopping online.
Okay,
shut up.
All right
is shave club.
Dollar Shave Club has
everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best.
Doctor and you never have to go to the,
still don't have to stoke, go to
this store, swing by the pack.
You get me a rack of bud light.
Yeah,
little fucking little nip there.
That's because they deliver everything
you need right to your dealer.
They keep you fully stocked on what
you use so don't, so you don't run up.
Here's how it works. Dollar Shave Club
has everything you need to get ready.
No matter what your getting ready for.
They have you covered head to toe for your
hair, your skin, your face, you name it,
they had it.
And they have this new program where they
automatically keep your stock stocked
up on the products you need.
You determine what you want when you want
it and it shows right up to your door
for once a month, what for once
a month to once every six months,
however you want to do it.
Plus with their hands,
some discount when you quit breathing
into the mic like a fucking pug
plus with their handsome discount.
The more you buy, the more you save.
And Right now,
dollar shave club has a bunch of status
that you can try for just five bucks
like their oral care kit.
After that,
the restock box ships regular sized
products@theregularpricegetsyoustatussetforjustfivedollarsrightnowatdollarshaveclub.com
slash burr that's dollar shave
club.com/bar or what have we got left?
Two more, two more. Oh,
look who it is. Simply stay
simply safe. Nia winds. You like to sit
around your house and filled simply safe.
Here's why I'm a fan of simply safe home.
Simply safe is prepared for
anything that gets thrown at it.
You just send it, honey. If
a storm takes out your power,
simply safe is ready and intrude.
Cut your phone line. Jesus.
Simply safe is ready.
Say they destroy your key patterns.
Siren Nia. Simply safe. We'll still get
you help the help you need, Ma. Sure.
Maybe it's overkill.
Maybe you don't need to be ready
for every worst case scenario.
Love how that dragon you back
through your own shit. Well,
why wouldn't I want to be a,
but that's what makes simply safe
home security systems. So great.
It's always ready. Simply save. Could
cost an arm and a leg, but it doesn't.
Instead they only charge you.
What's failure?
24 seven professional security monitoring.
Monitoring is just 1499 a month.
And there are no contracts,
no hidden fees, no like no contracts. And
then what they, when they don't show up.
I don't know who you guys are.
No paperwork. I'm not kidding.
They're not going to do it.
I recommend simply safe to everyone
I know you gotta check it out.
Go to simply safe.com/bird.
That's s I m P L I s a f e bird.com.
Simply safe.com uh,
to protect your home and family today.
Simply safe bird.com sorry,
I forgot the bird part.
Lastly, but not leastly borough. Sure.
Everybody loves it.
Donkey.
But have you ever thought about
owning one at Boro Dotcom?
Kidding borough makes clever
uncompromising furniture
for modern life at home.
Did you realize this?
Nia?
And as the days get shorter
and the weather gets colder,
you know you're going to be
spending more time at home,
on and on and on the couch and on
and on and got all hip hop there.
Make sure that that time well spent with
a sofa from borough handmade in North
Carolina,
Nia,
it's made in America by immigrants has
a built in Chattanooga in case that sofa
blocks a wall outlet.
You liked that Nia.
Nia, can you just, could
you be involved here?
This is the money.
Don't want me to like to breathe.
You don't want me like what I'm
trying to know. You can bring,
just gone into a microphone spectacle
and let you read your advertising and
you're still yelling at me like,
what do you want me to do here? Yeah,
that sounds great. They go, you gotta
be that person for, okay, great. Yeah.
He got the charger built into
the sofa. Yeah. That's amazing.
What's more burrow is
designed for comfort.
Exactly 17 inches off the
ground because that's the APP
chief from the bottom of a person's
foot to the back of their knee.
Includes a built in USB chargers.
So you never get to have to get up.
Let's go ahead. Let's do that.
Read it again. Okay, let's
do that again. All right.
I like that you said that's great, but
I want more emotion this time. Okay.
Alright. Includes a built in Usb
chargers so you never have to get up.
That's great. That's okay. No,
I didn't. Just just, okay. Was,
that's good acting, but I want late night
TV. People have fallen asleep. Okay.
You got to get them to buy a sofa
at two 40 in the morning. All right,
they're ready. Got It. I'm right.
Here we go. Keep it still wrong.
Includes a builtin USP charges
so you never even have to get up.
That's great. Oh, and even more.
Introducing new line of pillows.
Come on,
keep the energy up and throws
four unique collections.
Help you decide in your style.
I was terrible at f the
f ethically manufactured,
ethnically,
ethnically manufactured,
ethically manufactured with fair
trade. And good. We've certification.
Aw,
you can get your living room ready for
fall and save $75 $75 that's right.
$75 on a new Sofa by visiting
borough.com/burr for your $75 order.
Shipping is fast and it's free.
That's borough B. U. R. R
o W. Dot com slash. Berg.
It's $75 off your oral order. Sorry, Aura.
Thanks again to borrow
for supporting the show.
When a flight a fuck did they throw that
weight had? How's that spelled again?
B. U. R. R. O. W.
If this isn't the greatest couch with
a plugin phone charger you ever sat on.
All right.
What are we up to here?
31 minutes, Nia. Just like that. Yeah. I
swear to God. I love you to death and I'm,
I'm done getting into fights with you.
Okay. I'll ask both agree to that.
Have you noticed that? I've been
trying to say. You notice? Yes.
I have noticed that you have tried.
No. The old me would have taken
that bait. You know what this is?
That's not even a youth thing.
I was trying to be funny in that moment.
I've noticed,
I've noticed that you've tried.
I've been married too fucking
long to ever expect a compliment.
I know what the deal
is. Well, you should've,
you should've been doing this the whole
time. That's what it's going to be.
And this is what I want. This,
I'm better late than never.
This is what I,
and this is what I want you to do in here.
I want you to continue to not work on
yourself. Oh, here we go. Yes, yes.
And I, and I'm, I'm going to become,
I'm going to become such a good person.
People are going to start
whispering to me. Why are you,
she's horrible.
Welcome to my world now.
[inaudible] I'm working on myself.
You know that I'm working on myself.
You stop putting words in my mouth.
What are you Trump? What do you mean?
I'm great? You know, I'm
on myself. People upset.
No one's worked harder on themselves
than I have. I am the greatest worker
on myself ever. Um, anyways. Hey,
I want to thank everybody that's coming
out to Madison Square Garden. Um,
I am recording that night and please come
down and I have a couple of glasses of
booze. Get all fucking [inaudible].
That's right. Loosen up.
I'm going to have a great time.
I'm fucking going up.
D I've been going harder than ever
on stage just because of all of this.
They keep asking you
be there for Madison Square Garden.
I know it's going to be amazing because
the form was literally the best show
I've ever seen. You do. And I've known
you really isn't. I had lights count.
Yep. Um, it was like the
best show I've ever seen.
You do and I've seen you
do like an amazing shows.
But that farm one was like,
even when I talk to people about it now,
they'll just say it just from the
moment we walked in the door, like the,
just the whole energy was electric and
I think the crowd was really excited.
You had a great crowd that night. Like it
was just, yeah, the crowd was, was really,
really, yeah. It was just
great energy. And like Joe
and dean were bulges on their,
a game.
Like it was just,
it was Joe and dean walked out there
like they were doing a spot at the store,
which is like how you have
to be, right? Yeah, no,
they just went out there and they were
just like, Hey, what's up? And just, yeah,
went on. I was like, all right, well not
are intimidated by the venue I guess.
If they're not nervous, why
should I be non very uh, yeah. No,
it's a humbling experience in
go out there and just like,
I don't know if I ever get to do
this again. So I'm playing drums
during the day. Yes. That's,
that's like your new thing now is that
you play the drums and and do then jam
and then you,
then you're like,
I feel like you shake all the
nerves out of you by doing,
yeah. You just go, why don't you
just make a ton of noise? Yeah.
I did that at the garden and Boston.
I'm going to do it in Msg again.
And the farm too. Yup. Oh,
I played for like almost three hours.
My shoulder was killing me.
That's so great that they let
you do that though. Yeah. Yeah.
At first I thought that they
would think that, yeah, why?
What does this asshole doing that?
But then it's like this bands in there
all the time too and it up. Yeah.
And I think that they get a
kick out of the fact that, uh,
that we're acting like we won a
radio contest rather than coming in.
They're like, oh, another arena,
right? Yeah. We come here like,
so you can't believe
I'm here. Sure. I mean,
that's all we do. I saw Queens
of the stone age here that just,
I just freak out the whole time.
I'm there. Wait, are we now?
Talk about the party yesterday.
Oh, how much you crushed that
frigging party? We had a,
the second annual kid, Halloween,
maybe Halloween. Baby Halloween,
maybe Halloween party.
You know how nightclubs are 21 and over.
This is,
this was two years and under.
Bless. It was adorable, first of all,
but no, it was, it was really, yeah.
The one little kid dressed
like a hedgehog. Oh my God.
The two little kids dress like hedgehogs.
There's two hedgehogs at the party. Oh,
I know. I thought it was going
to be friction. Um, snoopy,
the no one family,
one family came dressed
as Charlie Brown and Lucy.
That was the parents and then snoopy
was the baby. Oh man, that's so cute.
Then we had the tires, the
tires, the tires. The parents
showed up and just their,
their bathrobes and pajamas and
the kid. Oh, someone's pajamas.
A very clever idea. You went out
and got us all skeleton costume.
Oh my God. Wait, can we
talk about your skeleton?
Cuss my skeleton slash pimp
outfit that you got me.
It was a giant onesy with feet and hands.
I didn't realize that there was like
gloves and feeding. It wasn't clubs.
It was all sewed into it. There
was no option. There was no option.
Then we found out later on that night
that there was actually like this ski mass
thing that you were supposed to put
over your head. Like are you serious?
It was. It was definitely freaky. Yes,
and then you had the
most craziest joke ever.
Yes. Last night. I go, Jesus Christ, I go,
there was a fucking ski mask
thing with that and then you left,
you said put that on and fuck me.
And I was even a even that
made me uncomfortable.
And I know you were fucking
joking obviously, but I
was like, Jesus Christ Nia.
Because it literally look like again,
you put it over your head and it was like
skeleton. Only thing that was missing
was the zipper mouth. So awful.
Yeah. That was a one and
done or put that on. Fuck me.
Unbelievable.
Oh my God.
Horrible. But no, that was,
um, that was a fun time.
Thank you so much for your
help with that. Great. Okay.
I, I'm gonna, I'm going to take
you to a Mike class at some point.
You literally have it laying
horizontal across your chest. I know.
Could I be like any lazier
right now my energy.
I'm comfortable now. I'm finally in a
comfortable spot. I got the blanket.
I feel good.
Yeah,
you were supposed to be working right now.
He's supposed to be just hating people
and you're sitting there looking look
like, uh, they took vacations together.
MMM.
All right. No, but the, uh, the caterers
were amazing. All the food was amazing.
And uh, thank you Twitter for
your ear playlist suggestions,
I think to people on Twitter.
But I want to thank you guys again that
you crushed it. It's a lot of good ideas.
You had all this great music and then all
of a sudden it would just go into like
thriller Michael Jackson and
everybody get all psyched with that.
And then it'd be similar to,
it'd be like baby Shakhti dut dut babies.
I was trying to do with that. Does
that song go once that's in your head,
you'd done? It's done. It's done.
And I had three different versions of
[inaudible]. Are you serious? Yeah.
I don't remember baby Shakhti
Ddd to do baby it did.
[inaudible]
baby check.
Mommy shucked it today.
It doesn't go dude. Dude, dude, dude.
No it doesn't. How does it go? It
doesn't do that. You didn't even hit,
you didn't even know what this
song was until I played it.
So how do you know how it goes? How
does it go then? I don't remember,
but it doesn't go like that. Dot.
Well, there's a few different versions.
There's a slower one that goes baby
shuck, Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo
Doo baby shark due to do to do,
that's the one baby shower.
Maybe Shark Dude. Dude, dude,
the fuck is up.
There's many different versions of your
face. Doo, Doo, Doo Doo
Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo.
Got your face
fast one though.
That was the first one I heard.
Maybe they did the, that was
the first one I heard. Oh me,
maybe it works with that voice and
then I heard BB and then there's an RMB
version one that I played
at the party as well.
I just firing on all cylinder.
Oh, there is spicy Margaritas.
Two of those bad boys.
All kinds of delicious food.
We had like the toys and the games out
for the kids. Yeah, it was a good time.
It was a good time. Yeah, and
now it's over. Now it's over.
Now I have to go return all
those tables and chairs.
How few with a little kid shares.
Oh.
And they actually sat in them Colorado
and they were coloring and putting
stickers on construction paper.
It was so cute.
I liked the little kids at that age.
Like they just like,
there'll be two little kids just look at
each other and another kid just runs up
super fast and then just stops.
And then he'd just stare at each other
and then they all just run to go to
something.
You know, our, um,
our neighbor texted me and she
was asking how the party was,
she has older kids and she was like,
you probably had a much more controlled
situation because her kids are older and
she's like, when they get older, once
it's like foreign up, she's like,
every party is completely
insane because it's,
their energy is all over the place anyway.
And then they have candy.
And she was like,
please and joy,
like the kind of controlled atmosphere
that you have with this age group.
But I was like, no, I know. That's
why I wanted to keep it to one under,
cause there's just insane,
right? Like don't you think?
Uh, no, I wasn't aware of
any of this storm front.
Well, apparently, well,
whatever, I'm going to comment.
Well, what are you going to do?
Yeah, I mean, whatever happens,
I know that me and my siblings did
tenfold to my mother, so I have a common,
um, all right, that's
the podcast. Um, now,
now you're going to be listening
to a clip of a uninformed,
I'm the first one and I don't
know how many years. 10 years. Uh,
that's gotta be on the Patrion page.
That is going to be debuting November 5th,
November 5th.
Excuse me,
I just burped November 5th.
Yeah. Talk to me about microphone, a kit.
You know what? You're right. See
that guys, that's how it works.
You to get along with your wife. She's
learned that phrase. You know what?
You're right. All right. That's
it. Uh, have a wonderful weekend.
You can set up job,
Deon one.
[inaudible]
I never one of those ones do it.
If I could go back in time.
I've worked in so many kitchens.
I've never seen so many jailbird.
I've never seen you get over and
fucking wash some. I've never,
we're going to get you. I've never seen
so many fat men do so much cooking.
It's like, Dude, oh, this doesn't make any
fucking, I know I've told you this story.
I got a classic one, a manager, right?
The manager where I
worked, uh, I was a busboy,
so I used to have to mop up around the
oyster bar and they had like the black
and white towels like the old
improv's used to have. Right.
So I'm mopping that up and will
always be a fucking mess. Yeah.
And then I would have to mop up and
clean the men's room and the women's room
and a women's room always look like,
you know,
like the Yankees just won the world
series. It was just like toilet paper,
a ticker tape all over the whatever.
It was just,
it was a fucking mess in there guys.
It was just a pissed all over the place.
So I go in there to clean the
bathroom and my manager is in there.
He's got the water on full blast and
he's brushing his teeth while puking.
Swear to God, he's prejudiced.
He's got that. Maybe go like,
oh,
hello.
And he had the water keep going.
Then he just kept brushing his
teeth and I was sitting there,
I didn't know what to do.
Aw.
They just
kept brushing his fucking teeth and then
he just saw and then he played it off
going like, ah, you know,
it goes brushing the teeth
sometimes it makes me gag.
And I'm thinking about doe fucking Jim,
the toothbrush down your throat,
your fucking whore.
And it wasn't till I was only 19 right.
So what is it until years later that I
was like, oh, he was fucking hung over.
He just was fucking puking up alcohol
and he was probably standing
there puking than I came in.
And then he was just trying to act
like he was brushing his teeth.
Like I wasn't going to notice
that he was fucking puking,
but I was standing there, go over
the brush. Gee, that guy was stuck.
I was so funny. I remember he
go funny, believe it or not,
he ends up getting fired,
right? He goes, yeah,
he gets fired and then he
gets a job managing another
restaurant as they all do.
Yeah. You walked out onto the floor and
an eight ball fell out of your pockets.
You fired. And then like they
won't even go across town.
They'd be across the fucking,
like the, the Strip mall.
So this guy ends up getting another job,
making way more money and I swear to God,
he showed up like a week
later with his new job,
he had bought a brand new car and he came
over to peacock, like we gave a fuck.
And he pulled up with some
white Subaru sports cars.
I can't remember what the fuck
he had and he just kicked can,
he just was sitting there at
the fucking bar with this cat,
ate the canary smile on his face. And I
said, hey man, how are you doing? I said,
hey, is that your car out day is
like, yeah, I want to drive it.
And he slid the keys across the barge.
Jesus Christ. Yeah. I swear to God,
it was like I was in
roadhouse. The, uh, dude,
restaurant workers are like
dirty cops. They just get
shuffled off. Oh yeah. Dirty.
The 42nd precinct. Oh yeah. They're
there. Once you're in, you're in, dude.
It doesn't matter.
What do you got?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
no.
Monday.
Oh,
des.
Yes.
Hey, it's Becca, right?
Oh,
you can't, you can't. You
can't. You can't. You cons.
What's going on? It's Bill Burger.
It's the Monday morning podcast.
That was the worst fucking mix ever done.
I don't give a fuck. I'm in my pajamas.
What do you want for me?
The Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
November 1st. Oh my God.
It's almost thanksgiving.
This motherfucker is back on iTunes,
so everybody relax.
Your fucking smart phones.
Relax. You can download it. It is
back. I don't know why it's back.
I don't know why it went away.
It went away.
Like somebody drunk mother a
couple of months, you know,
couple of months back, she started
drinking. The Shiv is Rico. Yeah.
Got a little tipsy.
She went out to the bar and she never
came back and then all of a sudden she
just comes walking back into our
lives. No apology. No nothing.
Ma. Where the fuck you Ben? Yeah,
Jerry. Just it alone. All right.
She's sober. Um, yeah, I dunno. I Dunno
what happened with fucking iTunes.
I don't know what I said. I don't know
what I did. There was no explanation.
Actually there was an explanation, but
it's too fucking boring to get into. Um,
I used the wrong punctuation,
some sort of quotes when I put the
money more. No, I use an Asterick,
you know, little Barry bonds, little
Sammy Sosa, little Mark McGuire,
little Roger Maris action. When I
went to go post it and then they just,
they just took me off, you know, and
like some mean little seventh grade girl,
they just refused to talk to me.
We were BFFs and it was fucking
over and there was no reason,
complete overreaction.
So for the last fucking 35
days or so, we were like, to,
what the fuck are, you know, I thought
we were friends. So anyways, we're back.
We're back on iTunes and if you guys have,
you know,
your smart phones or whatever the
hell it is, you can download it.
You can download it to your iPod, you
can go right back to fucking off at work.
Isn't that great? Isn't that phenomenal?
Doesn't that make you feel good?
Uh, as you can see, uh, um,
I kind of sounded excited.
This is like one of these,
these episodes where I'm going to be
a little manic because not only am I
excited that the, I uh, the
podcast is back on iTunes.
I'm also a freaking out cause I have
a ton of shit that I have to do today.
So to be honest with you guys,
after this wonderful Intro,
I'm just here to tell you I really don't
have time for you fuckers this week.
What are you think about
that? Ah, um, all right.
What are we going to talk about this
week? Let's, let's, let's open the page.
Open the page. Nia, closing the
door cause I'm being too loud.
What's it matter in the
he afraid of the funny,
she's in a mood, but are they always, ah,
I got a smile and it really annoyed
me this weekend. I was sick,
I was in Saint Louis,
meet me in St Louis.
Louis meet me at the fair though.
Tell me the lights are
shining and he plays,
but there we will dance though.
Who Ci Coochie you will be something else
that is a sexual innuendo but it's the
19 fucking forties.
So we can't talk about banging.
I'm sorry. Mitch Miller Baby.
What was my first album?
Sing along with Mitch in the gang and
I just found out that motherfucker just
died. That son of a bitch was
like 90 something years old.
Still put in Grecian formula in
his beard. God bless them. Um,
AH, Jesus. Why did I sing
that stupid fucking song?
I forget what the Hell I was going
to talk about. Let's go back.
Let's try to go back into the memory bank.
I was in Saint Louis this week and uh,
I did a benefit for the children,
John Carney, sa carnies kids.
I did that a Friday night, Saturday
night. I did the funny bone,
two shows at the funny bone and want to
thank who showed up at a wonderful time
out there. And, uh,
if you guys want to go back in time
and reach back into a little bit of
Americana that you feel was lost during
the last 20 years of horrific moves.
You know, I've got an idea.
Let's come up with Nafta.
Let's stand all the manufacturing
out of this fucking country.
And then Sunday we want a fac we
gotta compete with sweatshop Labor.
Does that sound like good idea?
I think that's a good fucking idea.
I have an idea. Let's have a war. Fuck.
Let's have two wars at
the same fucking Tam.
How are we going to pay for it? Yeah,
we'll borrow money from chatter.
That sounds good to me.
Why am I blaming it on southerners?
I Dunno why? I Dunno. Why?
Cause the last two guys were from Arkansas
and then the other guy was from Texas,
you know. Ah. You realize before Obama,
the last two presidents should
have been on the food network.
I one of those barbecue offs.
You know, I'm trying to compete.
Who has the best fucking sauce?
Mas Vinegar based in his,
he's in [inaudible]. Okay.
That's that sweet stuff.
You put that sweet stuff phone
cause you don't know how to cook.
Good please mate. You know, not a good,
you know how to cook good pace. Me,
you don't need go desk sweet stuff.
You can put a little bit leaner growling.
I come from the foot hills North
Carolina, we use, we use vinegar start,
he started using that. Then that sweet
stuff he talking about Kansas City. Um,
anyway,
so if you want,
if you want to reach back into America
a little bit and just a, if you want,
you get,
if you have children and you want them
to see what this country used to be like
back in the day when you
could eat cheeseburgers and
French fries and a fucking
drink it goddamn chocolate
malt and somehow not end
up being a fat fuck because
there wasn't all these goddamn
preservatives in it. Right?
Isn't that what makes you fat?
How come it people used to eat like no
one knew shit about nutrition in the
1950s. Yet everybody kind of
seemed like they weren't in shape.
You know, granted they were
fucking openly racist and uh,
grabbing their secretaries
asked every five seconds,
but they were in much better shape.
If you want to go back into time,
go to Saint Louis because St Louis is
one of the few places I have been to and
the last eight years that you can still
smoke in comedy clubs and you could
smoke in bars and people just light
up. And I, and I was amazed by it,
you know,
even though I kind of remembered that you,
I hadn't been there in five years, but,
uh, there's just certain states they just,
they just, um, they don't give a shit.
Like when they see the surgeon
general come on TV, they just like,
I don't recognize that uniform. He
ain't no fucking Americans. So, uh,
they completely ignore it. So if you
want to go back in time with your child,
you know,
if you're tired of reminiscing with your
adolescent son or daughter about how I
used to be able to go in a bar
and have a drink and a smoke, um,
why not live it?
Why not go to Saint Louis?
I think that they should add that to
their tourist attractions right up there
with the, uh, with the arch,
the gateway to the West so to speak.
I actually hung around for an extra
day yesterday and I went to the, uh,
the Saint Louis Rams game
first. The, uh, the, uh,
the Carolina Panthers and is
boring as part of the game was,
it was kind of exciting to watch a team
that you could tell was going to be
fucking good in about a year or two.
The ramps,
remember you heard it
first, November 1st, 2010.
Right here. Sam Bradford I think
is the real fucking deal. Guys.
Cool as a cucumber.
He's driving the damn team down the field.
Even though his top three receivers
are all out for the season.
He was throwing it to
white guys all day long.
That's how many injuries
they have on the team.
They're all the way down to
the white receivers people.
And I know what you're going to say.
What about Wes Welker. All right.
Wes Welker, that white dude who played
for Denver, there's not a lot, you know,
but slowly but surely, I don't know if
you've noticed the white guy is, is,
is making a little bit of
inroads back into, into some, uh,
what do they call those
positions? Performance are
a speed positions. You know,
there's a couple of white running backs.
Did you ever think you're going to see
that again? I mean, I couldn't believe it.
I'm in Saint Louis.
People are smoking within structures and
there's a white quarterback thrown into
a white wide receiver.
It was unbelievable.
I was waiting for Larry Zonker to come
walking out on the field with that little
fucking, you know, the two
bars across his face. And then
that one, the, the, the, the,
the horseshoe we had on top.
That's why I don't fucking
respect the goddamn 72 dolphins.
They had two white running
backs. Okay. And you go, oh,
we went undefeated. Did Ya?
Who'd you play in the third week? Some
group of people from the fucking why MCA?
You fucking pricks? What'd your 14 you
40? I'll use when 14 fucking games.
14 game season.
You cheap bastards.
Oh God. That fucking lost
to the giant still hurts.
But you know what feels good watching
the Goddamn jets lose nine to nothing.
I love it.
And here are the Patriots are
right in a rebuilding fucking year.
We've got a bunch of Goddamn kids
play in defense. We Trade Randy Moss,
all these asshole jet fans of fucking go
hoe and do patriots fucking quit with a
nervous they could be to
judge you to gay p two p.
That's what a great coach Bill Belichick
is. All right, you fucking assholes.
How do you like that six and one with
a bunch of children play a defense
six and won best record in the NFL.
I don't know how the fuck we did it.
I gotta I gotta admit I'm not gonna.
I'm not going to believe
that we're actually going to
do something and unless we,
we beat the Steelers and uh,
we played the Steelers in the jets and a,
even if we go one and one,
if we're competitive, then
I'm going to get excited. But,
uh, you know, I don't know.
Our defense at this point is
halfway to be in good, I feel.
But I'm, I'm telling you don't
sleep on the fucking rams.
I should have bet those sons of bitches.
I should,
I had no idea what was going on down
there in Saint Louis and they got that
maniac. Uh, the fuck
is his name, number 55.
That kid from Ohio state, God
dammit, what the hell was his name?
Something itis.
Dad's like a professional wrestler.
He went in and he got a sack and he
did the fucking Hulk Hogan, you know,
putting his company's air. And then he
did the flex then and then I was great.
It was fucking great.
I don't know what the jets lost.
I'm so fucking excited. Cause all those
assholes and you know, it's funny,
I didn't get one goddamn fucking email
from any of those goddamn jet fans who've
been given me shit all these
weeks. You know, fucking idiots.
They're not idiots. You know what they
are? They're hopeful. Sons of bitches,
they haven't won in 40 years.
They get excited about little things
like drafting fucking Mark Sanchez
San Shies. You know what's going to be
the end of the jet season if one of your
unbelievably awesome offensive lineman
goes down with an injury that fucking
goddamn mediocre overrated jackass.
Overrated this week,
mark fucking Sanchez,
that gay managing jackass.
Good Lord fucking sit behind
the goddamned Berlin Wall.
You could have fucking rex Grossman in
there and he could throw for 180 yards.
No picks. You're not impressing
me. Speaking of that man,
I had the fucking reds.
I got my ass handed to me yesterday.
Thank God I picked the dolphins.
I had the dolphins getting
one and Cincinnati and uh,
I love the dolphins.
I loved them.
They got that fucking defense and the
Bengals when sputter and all fucking years
. So I said, fuck it. I'll take
that. So I won that one. Then I had
the Redskins, Donovan McNabb going
into play the lines, but typical me,
I don't read up on sports.
I didn't know that their quarterback
was coming back for the lions.
I don't even know what his fucking
name is. Stafford, something like that.
I had no fucking idea. And then when,
when the whole game's on the line,
including my fucking money,
you'd take Donovan McNabb out
and you put in Rex Grossman,
the guy,
the cult secretly fucking paid
off the bears to be quarterback.
So Peyton manning could finally get his
fucking ring after they went into the
Goddamn rule book and change the rules
so Peyton could fucking actually beat the
patriots in the fucking playoffs.
Playoffs.
Um, whatever. I'm just talking shit.
Um, I actually took the colts tonight.
As much as I hate it,
I'm going to have to fucking root for
the colts cause I could go up to games on
Paul versa, who almost went all in
for last week missed. I know sports.
Paul Versey are you listening?
He went one in three yesterday and I uh,
I've gotten one or two, but I have, I
have the colts tonight. Loving them,
loving them to avenge their
loss to the Houston Texans.
I don't even know what the fucking
spread is cause I don't give a shit.
I really don't give a shit. I just
like pissing people off. Let's get,
let's get on with the podcast.
Um, it is November 1st everybody.
And uh, did you guys all have a nice
Halloween? Did you have a nice Halloween?
Did Brett Farve die yesterday? Did
you guys see that shit? Jesus Christ,
he looked like somebody kicked
him in the balls from behind
the way he was laying there with
his fucking knees up to his dealer.
He was going to get an enema. It's
like, what are you doing dude?
You own every fucking record out there.
Good and bad.
What are you going for? The mediocre
ones now I don't understand this guy.
It's just, just, just walk away.
I don't like how he's patting himself on
the back too. You know, I got hit in a,
that's a hit that you know, I don't think
a lot of people would've got up from,
but you know, I had on some
wrangler underwear and I just said,
fuck it. He is a tough son
of a bitch. But you know,
I don't know what he's trying this. His
wife hate him at this point. Um, yeah,
keep playing. I don't give a shit show
when your dick to everybody. Fuck you.
Um, oh, here's something that I actually,
I never even addressed.
All right. Brett said that,
that annoyed me and Kobe Bryant a couple
months ago when Lebron was doing his
big decision thing,
when he finally decided to go to Miami,
Coby made this statement,
I forget if I brought this up.
They ask Coby if he would've done the
same thing. And he goes, no, I wouldn't.
I would've stayed. And a, I thought
that was kind of cunty. It's like,
well, that's easy for you to say
when you fucking play for the Lakers.
And they bring all the free agents to you.
You know,
there's been no reason
for you to fucking leave
your whole fucking career.
They've been bringing you guys,
you were playing in Cleveland.
You would've left Colby.
You almost left because you didn't like
Shaq. Either he goes or I go, I'm sick.
Or when a championships,
um, it's all fucking career.
They brought your shack.
Dennis Rodman, Phil Jackson,
Karl Malone, Gary Payton,
Robert Henri, Pau Gasol,
fucking that dude who
choked the people at I. Off.
I don't watch fucking basketball.
Who's that guy there?
A Jesus Christ. So he's still a bit of
bottom. I say his name every Goddamn night
she was Jermaine O'Neal slid across the
floor, punch that guy in the face. Ah,
whatever the fuck his name is,
the trails. Fucking third cousin.
They brought you a list.
Fucking free agencies.
Your entire Goddamn Korea. I thought that
was a real conti move for someone who,
who is allegedly Lebron's friend.
But how funny is it watching, uh,
Lebron's people sitting there trying to
do damage control with these stupid ass
fucking commercials?
Trying to get people to a,
I don't know what changed their
opinion about them. I mean,
I could really give a shit. It's just
like, just fucking go play basketball.
I don't give a fuck. What
would I do that? Well,
what would I, what would I do? I would,
I would not even be able to make it on
my eighth grade basketball team if I
remember correctly. So I, I don't
know what I would do. Lebron.
I haven't had to make decisions
like anywhere near that level.
I don't care.
I don't care about you and yet talcum
powder and your little fucking ritual.
I could give a shit.
Just fucking go out and entertain me.
I don't need you to try to Redo your
fucking image, you know? I don't know.
So what?
You can make $100 billion.
Don't you have enough? Isn't it
enough? You get free sneakers?
I don't even know what
I'm talking about people.
I'm just fucking thinking about all the
shit I have to do for the rest of the
day. That's what I'm doing
in this podcast right now.
I'm cleaning the dirt out
of my keyboard and uh,
speaking of what,
you know what I'm dying to do,
I'm dying to fucking replace
some of the tile in my bathroom.
You know, this is the latest
thing I'm obsessed with.
I'm obsessed with learning how to fix
shit around the house because I'm going to
buy a house and I'll be fucked if I'm
going to pay some fucking mouth breathe
and jackass with Dickies hanging off
his goddamn ass to come in there and
overcharged me for parts cause he wants
to have a fucking kegger that weekend.
You know, so if you want to
learn how to do shit right,
I hear you do it. You do it in the
apartment that you live in. It.
See like my dog clot up some of the,
uh,
some of the trim around
the door and a man,
it's a fucking joke. I'm looking
at it going, this is this.
This can't be this fucking difficult.
I'd go down to, hey, home depot,
they got precut shit down there,
so all I gotta do is get the shit
that's the same fucking size.
I trim it off the bottom.
Make sure it fits.
Slap it on there. Right?
Who cares if I fuck up?
It's not my place.
It's all a little bit of pain over it.
Nobody's going to notice my landlord
doesn't listen to this podcast, does he?
No. Seriously. I want to, I want to learn
how to fucking do that. Some of that shit.
I already know how to take a toilet out.
Can take the whole fucking thing apart.
I know how to take a fucking sink out now.
I don't know how to do that shit.
I just watched a couple youtube videos,
but it gave me confidence.
I'm confident with the sink that you,
you fucking set down into the counter.
That one that you got
to go underneath with.
I don't know how that's when
you're dealing with gravity.
I like the one that sits down in it.
You can just unhook everything and then
figure out how to hook it back up later.
You know,
you go to turn on the hot water and all
of a sudden the garbage disposal goes on
in the fucking kitchen. I want to
learn how to do that shit, but, uh,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about. All right, let's, let's, let's,
let's get to some youtube videos
of the week people, shall we, um,
first one and these are all gonna
be on the, uh, the Mlm, podcast.com,
the official website of the Monday morning
podcast that is back on iTunes as you
heard earlier with my horrible
singing. Um, all right, here,
they all are in, these aren't,
these aren't even youtube videos.
These are videos that I got everywhere,
but youtube because a,
everybody's on Youtube,
so I'm trying to go a little bit outside
the box with some of the shit that
people send me. Um, this is one.
Um, ah, shit, I didn't know
what the fuck to call it.
Just go to the [inaudible] podcast.com
and check this one out. Um,
a buddy of mine stand up, comedian,
Rob Cantrell. Fucking hilarious.
Really original guy. Um,
comedian and I think, um,
I think it was the first season of
last comic standing. He was on it.
That's the first time I
saw him and I was like,
I like this dude because he doesn't seem
like he's trying to win the competition
as much as he's trying to give
these people some quality stand up.
And then you had the other guy fucking
going around with the Goddamn Ginsu sorts,
fucking spinning it around. So of
course America votes for him. Right?
That's how they do it. Give me some
shiny shit. That's what I'm voting for.
Um, he did a thing about why pot
should be legalized in this country.
He made a great fucking
video that's supposed to, uh,
it's supposed to be like the
beginning of that movie patent. Um,
check that one out. Uh, there's
another one, a dude with Nub, k Kaos,
another guy, a to guy with a, yeah,
he has only one arm and then he has
part of another arm and he fucking,
he's in a,
I dunno what they're doing,
movie tie and he movie knocks the other
guy's fucking ass at down under the camp
canvas.
Um,
next one is a touch my body karaoke fail,
uh, with some English subtitles even
though the guy's singing in English.
And the last one actually comes from the
dude who runs the MM podcasts who, uh,
if you want to really,
if you want some advice on gambling,
this is the guy he's on
a fucking hot streak,
a crazy in coffee shop.
Starts yelling at Mexican dude.
So there you go.
There's your videos that you can watch
while you're at work or working out or
whatever. Um, I got a lot of, um,
emails last week from me imitating
those dudes on the corner,
so called white man. That shit.
Remember that last week, um,
somebody set out that impression of the
street preacher with the bad pa was spot
on and fucking hilarious.
There's a guy shouting in Spanish into
a blown out PA on the weekends in my
neighborhood, there's two churches. Uh,
there's two churches on every block
and even the immigrants, immigrants,
residents, even the immigrant residents,
these, this is all a misspelled here.
Immigrant residents grimace
and give him dirty looks.
How do you say quit shouting
and fix your levels in Spanish?
That is a reoccurring thing that I
have found straight across the board.
And when people go out, I don't give
a fuck black, white, Latino, Asian,
I don't give a shit. They never
have the levels correct in their PA.
I think there's so passionate about their
politics that they never really, uh,
I don't know.
And it's such a grass roots
actually,
when you think about it,
do you really think Obama knows
how to use a mixer? How old is he?
Yeah, he probably doesn't.
He's like fucking, I don't
even know how old the guys,
I have not paid attention to politics in.
I don't even know when, I have no
fucking idea when I just, I wanted,
whenever I stopped talking
about conspiracy theory
theory cause I just got so
depressed about all of
this shit. Um, you know,
started reading up on banking.
Like here's a,
here's something interesting here.
I,
this is one way I kind of see both sides
of this. This guy sent me this letter.
He said that bill,
listen to this shit.
So my wife and I are looking at
buying a house. Uh, like you,
I am not the biggest fan of bank.
So instead of putting all my
money in a savings account,
I had been saving some cash on the
side and keeping it in my dresser.
And there's a smart place to put it.
Why don't you stick it in the mattress?
There's another place, you know, dude,
if you ever had that money stolen by
somebody breaking into your house,
that burglar should have been dressed
up in the black and white stripe shirt
with the uh, uh, lone ranger.
I'm a fucking a bank robber mask.
Maybe.
Maybe you're just saying,
you put it in your dresser,
your actually put it somewhere else,
you know you got you gotta,
you gotta be a little more creative
than that. Anyways, he says, well,
when my wife talked to the bank about
getting a loan, they asked us our incomes,
how much money we saved and how we
would be paying our down payment.
My wife told them about our
savings and everything was fine.
She then told them that I had
cash saved up on the side.
They immediately stopped her and said
that the cash could not be used unless
there was an explanation for how I got
it and a paper trail to back it up.
The banks look at your financial history
bank statements and your spending
habits to determine if you really could
save however much cash you actually
have. A, since some of my money is cash,
I've won from poker games and old
stuff. I sold on craigslist, craigslist.
I have no paper trail for it.
The only way that I can now use it for
our house is to get my parents to lie and
write a note explaining to the bank that
they gave me the money as a gift and
I'm not sure if that will work because
I don't know if they will check my
parents bank rescue records to confirm
that the whole policy is bullshit.
I understand that the bank's fucked up
and had to foreclose on a lot of people
and they want to make sure that I'm
not paying for a house with drug money,
but come on.
This essentially means that if I'm walking
down the street and find $20,000 in
cash in an alley, take it and
try to use it as a down payment.
The banks won't let me because
there's no record of how I got it.
This whole ordeal really pisses me off
and I'm pretty sure it goes back to what
you trying to say about how the government
is trying to phase out cash money. Uh,
no, that doesn't, that's,
that's one of those double standard
things that they do where you have to
produce all this paper trail stuff just
to show that you're not a piece of shit.
But they, on the other hand, the
Federal Reserve I'm talking about, um,
they've never been audited and we gave
them $1 trillion bail out money and it
just disappeared into thin air.
They can't say who got it or where it
went and they're not being audited.
But you on the other hand,
you know,
you sell an old skateboard and your
original fucking place station,
you win some money down the street and
in poker, you know, a poker tournament,
none of that Shit. You know, you're
supposed to pay taxes on all of that shit.
And if you found 20 grand coming down
the street, what you're supposed to do,
you're supposed to report it, bring
it down to the police station. Okay.
And hope that those fucking
guys don't dip into it.
And I guess after a certain amount of
days, uh, it legally becomes yours,
but then you have to pay taxes on
it and all that bit. All that shit.
And all after the fees,
you're probably left with
anywhere from eight to 10 grand.
That's how your legally supposed to do it.
And what's annoying to me
is that you and I are up.
We're held to those legal fucking
standards, but banks are not.
Banks are supposed to be watching
our money, keeping it safe. And they,
for basically,
I don't know how many goddamn years
we're loaning it out to fucking homeless
people, given six figure loans
to them. And Lo and behold,
when these fucking people defaulted on
their goddamn loans and the whole thing
went into the shitter, the government
fucking bails them out. They're like,
we're too big to fail.
They fucking bail them out.
They keep the bail out money and now
they added all these cunty surcharges to
urine your account in my account.
So yeah, that's, I dunno, this is what
you, this is what you do with your case.
If you have cash on the side,
uh,
use it for shit that you can
actually pay for in cash, I guess.
I mean or save it in case
your bank ever goes, uh,
goes belly up and there's
a run on your bank.
You won't be sitting there with your
pockets turned inside out going,
can I at least have some yogurt?
But yeah, it is practically.
Um,
the more you read about banking,
you'll start to understand
why corporations and,
and, and, or super rich like
you know, the entrepreneurs,
why these guys have offshore accounts
and all that type of shit because he's
guys basically I think read up on banking,
which you would have,
do you read up on the tax laws and
you see how the whole game is played.
You see who gets penalized and who
doesn't and you start thinking Jesus is
fucking ridiculous.
So let me get this straight.
When I get to this level of
wealth, all of a sudden, um,
rules don't apply to me.
Okay,
well let me work my ass off
to get to that level. Oh wait,
I can't cause they keep taxing the shit
out of me. Oh, I get it. I got to do some,
there will be blood shit. I
mean, I'm really overly simple.
Simplifying the whole fucking thing.
But that's basically how it goes down.
I mean, that bank is not going to
take that risk on you. You know,
I got some cash on the side
that's actually good banking.
You can't have somebody just come
in and be like, uh, a listen,
I got to be really stereotypical.
Now I'm going to be Italian.
I'd already shit on fucking southerners.
Why not do an Italian stereotype?
A I got,
I got a,
I got good credit and I got did say
I got this 50 grand in this side.
Where did I get it? A why don't you let
me worry about that. All right. You know,
I, I, you know,
somebody else actually sent me something,
uh,
about banks here.
Hang on one second.
Let me read this and annoying more
people actually majored in economics or
economics. However the fuck
you say it. Uh, here we go.
Here we go.
Let me read up on this shit here.
You guys get on board with this shit.
Well, I don't give a fuck. All right.
I do give a fuck, but I didn't
care. I wouldn't be asking,
but I'm going to continue.
Hey Bill,
I've been thinking some about something
you said about taxes on your podcast.
It was about you trying to build,
build up a pile of cash and how the
government governments hitting you up for
tax money at every opportunity.
Yeah, that's my thing.
I'm trying not to put
money in the stock market.
I'm just trying to stick it in the bank
or whatever and they just tax the living
shit out of me. But if I stick
it on the crap table, right,
which the fucking stock market is,
if I throw it in there,
then they have no problem with it, then
all of a sudden they give me a tax break.
Hey, get over here and
play the fucking game. Oh.
Um, so anyways, uh, that's
anyway, let me get back to this.
Uh, they hit you up for tax
money for every opportunity,
but that there are rich folks out
there who've already got there,
so they don't want to get, they don't
want anyone to get rich after them.
There really is something to
that. Yeah, they got, they got,
they have to keep you did,
they can't have people making fucking
money and actually being able to keep it
because if they do,
then nobody would work.
We would just fucking kick back and relax
and maybe you have a chance to enjoy
ourselves.
Maybe sit by his stream in the Lotus
position or whatever the fuck it is you
want to do. They want you to run on the
wheel until you're fucking drooling.
And then they want whoever you created
to then take care of you in a nursing
home. And then if you can't,
they just want you to die. Um,
I tweet somebody. Okay, I tweaked, I
twigged I didn't know what that means.
I twigged onto this.
About a year ago when I was having a
discussion with a friend about progressive
income tax,
he seemed to think that it takes from
the rich to give to the poor and the
progressive income taxes.
Anticapitalist it's not though,
because I don't even know what
the fuck any of this means here.
Because earned income tax are always
higher than rates on dividends and capital
gains income. Let me, I get it.
I could read that much slower because
earned income tax rates are higher than
rates on dividends and
capital gains income. Okay.
So basically money that you
already have that's being invested,
the tax rate is lower than someone who
out there earning the nonworking air or
era's who survives on dividends and
capital gains from a family fortune like a
Paris Hilton.
Uh,
their income tax is at a much lower
percentage than a working person with an
equivalent income. So basically if
you're sitting around in your ass,
you're some fucking luck. Lucky
rich kid, the money that you're,
that you basically inherited
that you are earning off of,
there will be blood great
grandfather that you had.
The tax rate will be lesser for the Paris
Hilton Kid than someone like me if I
could earn, if I was earning that same
amount of money. Does that make sense?
Make sense to me? Um, I hope I explained
that in a way you understand it.
All right. The system punishes,
uh, work and reward rewards,
ownership with tax rates that provide
incentives for one kind of economic
activity over another.
I based this on my
experience with my Canadian.
This guy broke up with my, the Canadian
system. And before I emailed you,
I had to use Wikipedia confirmed to
confirm that the u s system works pretty
much the same way. And right there, this
entire email gets thrown out the window.
Wikipedia, sir, what are you fucking me?
Maybe it does make sense on the podcast.
Let's go with this Wikipedia information.
The worst part of it is that by
work is less valuable than capitol.
The woman making $8 an hour at Walmart
is paying the same percentage of income
tax as the Walmart airs pay
on their dividends. Dividends.
A medical doctor, however,
pays more than twice as much,
and the doctor is patching
up the sick and wounded.
The incentives in the
systems are all wrong.
So you basically say
saying the borderline, uh,
poverty person and the rich people are
paying the same amount of taxes in the
guys in the middle. Me Or getting
the shit text out of them. Yes,
exactly.
Exactly.
That is my fucking life. God dammit.
I have to hit pause here. People, I,
I gotta I gotta blow my nose.
Hang on a second.
All right, I'm back. Sorry about
that. You don't what happened to me?
I was eating a bowl of wheat
checks too fast and uh,
I didn't chew up the wheat checks enough.
So they went down,
it was like swallowing,
chewing tobacco and it got sorta like,
there was just like a bunch of like, you
know, it was in the back of my throat.
So I was like, what did that? And it,
it, some of it went up into my nose,
so it was actually rechecks
one,
I'm having a rough Monday. You never
started your weed off your wheat,
your week off with some
wheat checks in your nose.
We checks a healthy part of the
checks family. Let me tell you guys,
I'm a big fan of the, uh, check cereals.
I like, we checks, I like corn checks.
I don't like rice checks.
You know what I mean?
It's like a fucking bad movie.
It's just weak.
It's just a week cereal. You know, I
don't like those cereals that are like,
oh my God, milk. That's what,
that's what rice checks does.
It just fucking shit quits. It's
acquitting cereal. You know,
corn checks has some fighting them.
Quick checks it like the jets.
We checks. I like the Patriots. We
checks their course the strongest.
Ah, you green mother fuckers you
lost this week. I don't like debt.
Nine to nothing.
I love the overpaid for your fucking
tickets and you're brand new.
Fucking sublet an apartment
with the that the giants own.
You know what?
They roll out a little bit of jet signage.
Do you really think that
you own 50% of that?
you sons of bitches.
What was it like to go to
that boring ass fucking game?
Kick three nothing.
J E t s.
What the fuck?
Now the couple of fucking hours of
boring football kick six nothing.
J e t is what a fuck.
All right,
kick nine nothing.
Go home.
Did the fireman cry this
week? Oh, I love it.
Overrated talking shit before
the season even starts.
Like you just won three super
bowls in a row. [inaudible]
underrated,
having your stomach stapled.
Rex Ryan is getting better
looking every fucking week.
Son of a bitch kind of has a
jaw line now, doesn't he? Um,
all right. Just to be fair, um, I've
got to make fun of Celtics fans. Uh,
overrated.
Channing overrated.
When you're up by 11 with eight
minutes left against the Miami Heat.
Did you guys watch that game?
Then all of a sudden they all stay started
roaring back and all the felt Celtics
fans just shut the fuck up.
And then once the game was,
was decided with 12 seconds left,
they started chanting overrated again.
That was a real fucking bitchy mood. That
was real bitchy. Yeah. That I, I didn't,
I didn't, I was embarrassed to be
associated with that franchise. All right.
Who's the moron? Who's to
started that chat? Um, all right.
That was, if that was, it was just a quick
little riff of underrated, overrated,
underrated.
Having your own fucking jet airplane
with a big bed in the back in a giant
seatbelt,
you know?
Beautiful woman to sit on your Dick
in a fucking ivy to put you to sleep.
You just wake up in New York. That's
all I want. That's all I want. You know,
that's all I want out of this business.
I don't eat, I don't need much.
I got to fly to New York people.
I'm going to New York on a Tuesday night,
take the red eye back to that motherfucker
and I'm doing a benefit for the
troops play in the beacon theater with a,
believe it or not,
this is,
this is the lineup on this show and
it's going to be been to three different
bases in Iraq in three
different bases in Afghanistan.
Jon Stewart is hosting.
Tony Bennett is a, I'm
assuming he's singing. I don't
think he's doing stand up.
Uh, Jerry Seinfeld, Bruce Springsteen,
Joe, Mikael, myself,
and I think a couple of other people.
All I'm doing is eight minutes,
but uh, I can't wait man. It's going
to be a, well, I don't want to,
I don't want to do the flight,
but it's going to be fucking awesome.
That's Wednesday.
I'm flying out.
That's why I'm telling you I've got all
this shit to do today because I got to,
uh, you know, I just
landed here last night.
I got to do the fucking podcast.
I have an audition today.
I'm pitching a fucking show today.
I got to, uh, pay my fucking bills.
It's the first of the month.
I got to do all that fucking horse shit.
And then I got to jump right back
on a plane tomorrow. You know,
it's one of those fucking weeks.
Speaking of that dude,
I flew out to Saint Louis last week and
there was some woman who was clearing
her throat
like twice a minute from like I would
guess about Utah to Jess into Kansas.
[inaudible]
you had this exact same way of doing it.
I swear to God,
I have never prayed for my
own plane to crash before.
But that was one of those moments.
I didn't want it to crash. You know,
I was just fantasizing that like there
was a crack in the fuselage and no,
and she, that woman just got sucked
out. So as I was fantasizing about,
this is how fucking crazy I took it.
I actually reached down and I tightened
my seatbelt and I mentally went over how
to put that fucking mask on my face
before I help the infant or child next to
me. I saw it, you know,
it was really disgusting the
way she was clearing it, throat.
She was talking really
loud on her cell phone.
Just everything about it was annoying.
And whenever I see a person like that,
the first thing I do is I look
for a wedding ring. You know, I,
when I don't see one, I th I
think thank God. And when I,
when I do see [inaudible],
I actually feel bad for the man or
woman that is married to that, you know,
how could it just like,
and actually I came up with
like a philosophical question.
You know that those
dull Sechi commercials,
the most interesting man in
the world, what do you think
would happen? Here's the,
here's, here's one for the, uh, the
pot smokers out there. All right.
What do you think would happen if the
most interesting man in the world met the
most annoying woman on the planet?
All right. I want you to know,
I want you to tell me what you think
would happen because I couldn't come up
with an answer to that question.
You know,
he is the most interesting
man in the world. Well,
I would like you to meet this contour
is sitting diagonally fucking behind me.
I'll,
speaking of that underrated fucking
movie macgruber does anybody rented that?
I don't know if you'd be happy if
you paid to go see it at a theater,
but fucking, you know, unless you
have a silly sense of humor like me,
because I would enjoy that
if I saw it in the theater.
Look at me even when I try to compliment
something I say in a dick way.
I think this is a funny fucking movie,
uh,
with a couple of really
insane monologues in it.
And uh, not to ruin anything.
Spoiler alert, spoiler alert.
I had to bring this up.
The last name of the,
the bad guy in the movie is cunt.
And I'm assuming it's spelt with a k, k u
n t, Z or something. But it's, you know,
we got, we have to get current. I Dunno.
It's soft mark. It's fucking hilarious.
It's one of those movies you want to
watch with the female in the room cause
she'd just be killing. This is stupid. You
know, you think this is funny. Oh my God,
that's grouse. Which will just
make it so much more funnier.
Macgruber two thumbs up from me baby.
All right,
this podcast is all over the place.
Let's move onto the next one.
I the advice section, why you would
ask me for advice. I don't know. Okay,
here we go.
I started listening to your podcasts about
three months ago and I really like it.
Thank you. I was inspired by a couple
of your albums on iTunes. Thank you.
Now if you ever hear me bitching
about people fucking download shit,
I'm not talking about you or be in
cheap cons. It's not you, uh, bup,
bup, bup, bup. I love
your comedy my whole life.
And recently I sacked up in one on
stage for a five minute spot for an open
night open mic night at a local comedy
club here in Portland, Portland.
I was really impressed by
the people that showed up.
Many of them were talentless Dick Holes,
but at least they have the guts to get
on stage and for that they deserve some
credit. Well, thank you sir.
Thank you for fucking extending
that olive branch to them.
Um, so I got up there in
front of a whopping 15 people,
one of which who was my girlfriend
and talk some shit. It was,
I was pretty nervous, but my voice
was steady and I was energetic.
But most importantly I got
people laughing. There you
go. That's all you gotta do.
It might not seem like much,
but a I had a high like no other,
I might stick with it.
Basically I write down a few prompts.
Now this isn't me people. I swear
to God, I know I suck at reading,
but just the way these, some of this
shit is written, I'm going to read this.
Basically the way this guy wrote it,
or actually exactly the way he wrote it.
I might stick with it.
Basically I write down a few prompts out
for stories and quips and go to town.
I feel like open Mike Nights might
be the only way to get some chops.
Doing my bits for friends or two into a
mirror doesn't have the same effect as a
bunch of strangers. I'm gearing up
to put some hard work into my act.
I would like any tips on how you get
you got your chops and how you practice
your wrecked all right.
Couple of things. Yeah. Yeah.
You can't run it by your friends
to do it in the mirror. Um,
he could maybe say it a few times in the
way of the club just so you can kind of
get the flow of it. Uh, but yeah, the
only way to do it is to do open mics. So,
uh, you know, I would
do that, just do that.
And I would also drop the attitude
that people who are starting out are
talentless Dickholtz than not.
They're fucking, you know,
if you saw me when I started out,
you would have thought that this guy
sucks because I did suck because I was
brand new at it. So you don't want
to do that. And for all you know,
the those air quote talent was Dick Holes
will some day be in a position in this
fucking business where they could
actually hook you up with something.
So I cannot stress how important it is
to have good relationships with fellow
comedians and everybody in this
fucking business that you can.
I'm not saying that you take it
to the point that you will acts,
you actually allow somebody to walk
all over you and treat you like shit.
I'm not saying that,
but don't walk around judging people.
That a fucking thing cut out on me again.
God dammit. I'm sorry. I've been to,
I'm putting together a new hour comedy
and I have a bunch of standup sets on my
fucking recorder that I
never ended up listening to.
Something else,
sir,
that you might want to do if you're
doing stand up is to record yourself and
listen to yourself.
So you can become better as a comedian,
but the key is you gotta listen to them.
Anybody can record them and then just
leave them on their fucking tape player or
they're fucking digital recorder, whatever
the hell you call this God damn thing.
Um, yeah, that's what I would, I
would tell you that man, seriously,
like you will be absolutely
fucking amazed with,
with the people that you think are
going to do something and don't,
and the people who you're like,
ah, that person, I don't know.
I don't think they're going to do shit.
And all of a sudden
they're directing a movie.
They're the head writer on
something. They create a show. Uh,
who knows what, you don't know
what anybody's going to do. So,
uh, yeah. You know, so I
wouldn't walk around. I mean,
I'm sure you're just right in that,
maybe to make me laugh or something,
but I'm just putting that out there.
All right.
Because I've seen people act like cunts
and then get treated accordingly by
these people that they thought
were beneath them or whatever.
It's just the worst fucking
thing that you can do in any,
any in life in general, treating someone
else like a like shit or whatever.
I don't know.
I don't understand why people,
it really makes your life a
lot more difficult. And uh,
some day when you die,
you know,
like there's going to be the only people,
only people at your funeral is going to
be a, you know, the, the fucking two guy,
the guy who drives the truck
and the guy who digs the hole
or the hearse I should say.
Um, yeah. So that's, that's
the advice I would give you.
Keep doing the open mics.
Um, it keep writing stuff,
tape record yourself and
uh, you know, and then,
and then be a good guy, be a
good guy, but then, you know,
be a good guy within reason. I
mean, like I said, don't, don't it,
don't take shit from people and then
also try to try to be hanging with the
people who seem the most motivated,
most positive,
that type of shit because you'll get
caught up in it and a, and Yada, Yada,
fucking Yada. That's basically
it. So we're coming to the close,
here are the podcasts and other kind of
short one this week just because, uh,
I do have so much shit to do here.
Um,
congratulations to the rangers in the
giants for your first world series.
A giants are up three games to one.
And I was getting nervous for
giant fans. I actually, uh,
I don't mind ranger or the giants.
I have no problem with either one of them,
but I was getting nervous for the giant
fans when they were up two games to none.
And then the rangers came back and won
one game and I was like, yeah, God.
And a lot of ways the giants are
kind of like how the red sox were,
except they're in the national league.
You know how the Red Sox were
back in the day where it was,
not only do they not win, they have
to rip your fucking heart out too.
And uh,
I don't know.
At the risk of pissing off ranger fans.
I think the giant fans
that I think they've had,
I think they've had about enough.
I think it's time for the sports
gods to let him up off the mat.
Give him a God damn world series and
range of fans. Who are you kidding?
Who are you? Honestly fucking kidding.
You know, you're all cowboy fans.
You know,
if the cowboys record was flipped right
now and Tony Romo was living up to the
potential, you know, you know,
you wouldn't be selling out
those world series games. Yeah.
Now I'm going to fuck you. I'd like
to arrange your sense fucking, uh,
who was that? Who is that fucking,
yeah. Who was that Guy Buddy?
Something or buddy bell that come here.
Jackass who played third base.
Yeah. Um, he's not a jackass.
It just sounded funny.
I'm trying to think of guys who played
for the Rangers when I was growing up.
What the fuck was it?
Somebody wrote something funny on the
Internet about how 10 years ago when the
Rangers signed a Rod, two,
a $200 million contract,
he vowed to one day lead them to the world
series and when he struck out looking
on the New York Yankees, he finally
delivered on that promise. Oh,
Bill, you're such a content. I know.
I am. Yeah, I am a content. Um,
I actually watched the Patriots game
and this, uh, the sports bar, uh,
in Saint Louis and there was his fucking
old guy in there who was basically,
he had like,
like nine sports buttons on his shirt.
He had this little glow stick with
them and he's one of those guys when he
yelled,
but it still wasn't loud.
It just kept going. Whoa. The Patriots,
uh, where the Cheetahs, but we always word
whoa.
And everybody was ignoring them and
anything the Patriots did was awesome.
Like this guy fucking
shanks, this punk, right,
right up the side of his
foot for the patriot. The,
as the ball is dropping to his foot,
the guys go on.
Oh,
what a kick.
Whoa. He's pissing off
everybody in the sports bar,
but he's too fucking old
to punch in the face.
But this is what killed me about
this guy was the people around me.
Golly, he fucking comes here every
week. He's unbelievably annoying.
And the worst thing is, is he has, he's
fans of like six different football teams.
Like he's a fan of the Patriots,
the bills and the dolphins.
They're all in the same fucking division.
And he's a fan of the Kansas City, uh,
chiefs. So the bills played
the chiefs, so no, what?
He cannot lose any, just sits
there the whole game. Oh,
what a throw. Oh, what an interception.
Like he just wants to win the entire
fucking time. Long story short,
I had to take a picture with the
guy because he started off cute.
You know what a cute old man. And
then at one point, um, if I was,
if I was drinking,
I would have engaged with this dude at
during the second quarter and been like,
hey, how the fuck can you be fans
of every fucking team? You old cunt.
I would've done that.
But fortunately I'm not drinking.
So it took me until the fourth quarter
where I started to give him shit.
But then in the back of my
head I was like, really, Bill,
are you really going to get
into it with this old guy? Um,
but by the end of it, he was
just kind of hilarious. Swag.
She took a picture with the guy and I'm
going to have that uploaded onto the Mlm
, podcast.com. And uh, what else do I got?
I got a hype a few gigs here before I,
before I sign off from this pod,
this podcast was an absolute clusterfuck.
I apologize. I had high hopes for it,
but uh, you know, like a lot of things
in life, it just doesn't work out. Um,
all right, what do we got here? All right.
I'm going to be at the
funny bone in Columbus.
This is really one of these podcasts
that I would've stopped and restarted 10
minutes into it, but I just don't have
the fucking time. All Right, Bill,
we've heard your excuses. You have to mop
your kitchen floor. Nobody gives a fuck.
All right. I'm going to be at the, uh,
the funny bone in Columbus, Ohio. Friday,
Saturday, Sunday, November
12th, 13th, and 14th,
and I'm going to try to go to that Ohio
state, Penn state game. That's my big, uh,
I don't want to be bored shitless
at the mall and Columbus move.
Then I'm going to be making,
uh,
the following week I will be in
Washington DC at the listener auditorium.
And that's on a Friday,
November 19th. On November 20th,
I'll be at comics at Fox
woods in Connecticut.
I get a lot of emails from people
from Connecticut being like,
do when he come into fucking Connecticut.
I'm going to be there to
beautiful new room. Uh,
everybody's been raving about it.
All the comedians who
have performed there.
So come on down and check out my new hour.
And then finally,
this is the one I need you to help on.
Look into your hearts.
I am playing the Moore Theater in Seattle,
Washington.
All right. For those of you
unfamiliar with the Moore Theater,
it is a legendary theater
in, uh, Seattle, Washington.
Um, I guess what a rock fans, grunge fans.
Remember that Pearl Jam Video,
I think it was even flow.
We burn pro when a Eddie vetter is
climbing out into the crowd and fucking
jumping off the balcony and
stepping on people's heads and shit.
That's where they filmed that. And I
have to sell a lot of fucking tickets.
I'm a third of the way there.
So if you,
and some of you are drunk buddies
want to come down for the love of God,
please come down to the show because a,
I got a ton of tickets to sell and,
and clear channel. I don't know what
they've done radio, but they've,
they've taken off, you know, my
guy up there was Marty Reemer,
which I heard he has a podcast now,
if you live in Seattle,
fuck those radio stations
that took them off.
Listen to his podcast because hopefully
I'm going to be doing that to hype my
show.
Uh,
I'm kind of running out of ways to hype
shows now with what they're doing to
radio. For those of you
out of the loop, uh,
I think clear channel basically wants
to have for Djs for the entire country.
And, uh, you walk into
these radio stations now,
they don't even have a receptionist.
They have an automated system
for you to figure out how to uh,
get to where you're going. I don't
know. It's you know, yet another thing,
and I'm sure you people who are all for
these kinds of technologies like I love
when people like trying to support
those automated checkout lines.
Like they always say the same thing,
you know,
and you're standing there looking at this
poor bastard behind the fucking Reggie.
You mean that person with the fucking
job you really want to see and be a poor
bastard.
What would you rather be?
A poor bastard behind a fucking a cash
register or a poor bastard you fucking
homeless and don't have a Goddamn job.
I hate when people do like dumb shit
like that just to try to enhance their
fucking point.
If you fucking believe in that technology,
support the technology,
don't start,
start saying what the person behind the
fucking registers thicket even though
I'm doing the same goddamn thing.
But I think I can go out on a limb and
say that most people would rather have a
fucking job than be homeless.
All right.
Lot of yelling this week, Bill, as
opposed to what every other quiet week.
Um,
and then the final two gigs of this year
before I take my month off and I begin
my martial arts classes, joking. Um,
I'm going to be at COBB's comedy club in
San Francisco. Uh, December 2nd, third,
fourth and fifth,
and I'm going to be at the Improv
in Bray, California, the 16th,
17th, 18th and 19th of
December. Uh, come on down.
This new hour is starting to take shape.
Actually had some guy come up to me, uh,
this weekend in St Louis and was like,
that was absolutely hilarious.
I didn't think it was as funny
as let it go, but I, I liked it.
It's like, thank you sir. Well,
it's not done yet, you know.
Thank you for starting to compliment
me and then giving me a little Dick.
Hey, you look great. You're not
as fat as you used to be. Um,
all right. And this guy, hey, he really
had a pudgy face. They really did.
He had one of those. He was a
white dude, but he was like so fat.
He was starting to look Asian. You
know what I mean? When he gets so fat,
your eyes like that, uh,
that precious girl, you know,
you know when the fat just starts building
up on your cheeks, all of a sudden,
you know,
that's how you start to look,
whether that be in an incredible way
to sell some fat burning products.
Are you so fat that you're starting
to look Asian in your eyes even though
you're not? Well, listen,
that is offensive. Well, line up by
the Italians in the southern dish.
That's what this podcast was this week.
I'm trying to get fired from
my own podcast. I'm trying to,
I want a lot of complaints and have
people say that I need to apologize.
Um,
two different groups of people so that
I could be fired from my podcast because
I think I need a fucking vacation
from the shit I really do. No,
I don't actually love doing this shit.
I just got too much shit to do this week.
So that's it. That's the end of this
fucking podcast. I'm uploading it.
I apologize for my singing.
I apologize for the scatter brained,
uh, podcast at this was, but I think,
I think I like to think that there was
some moments. It was a good rental.
Anyways, that's it. Uh, and thanks
to everybody who's been buying the a,
the old g his ringtone on the MLM podcast.
If you want to donate to the podcast
99 cents, look into your heart,
go to the [inaudible] podcast dot
[inaudible] dot com and download the, oh,
Jesus ringtone. I'm actually
getting a new cell phone this week.
I was going to try to hold out
for the new iPhone when it's, uh,
not the new iPhone, the iPhone
when it switches over to Verizon.
But my blackberry is shitting the
bed. I can't get emails on it. And,
uh,
the letter n doesn't work anymore unless
I fucking sprained my thumb pushing it
down. And, uh, I think I'm
going to get that droid phone.
What do you guys think about that one?
Is that a good one? I want Verizon.
I want to stay with, with Verizon
because as far as where I travel,
I'm going to get the droid.
I should have just gone out and gotten
the fucking thing and it just had you
guys shit all over me that it's a bad
goddamn phone as opposed to now where I'm
going to get like 50 different
opinions. Like do, do not get the droid.
It fucking sucks. Get this phone.
Okay. Um, yeah, I have Verizon.
Keep that in mind. Suggest
a smart phone for me. Okay.
That is it. Thank you. One and all. I
hope you guys have a great God damn week.
And uh, and that is it. That
is it. That is a park. Ah,
Jesus Christ. What a
horrible editing. And that is
really bill. Really? Yeah.
That's all I got. This
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
oh.